[Musique]
dieu bénit chacun de nous
survie mois
[Musique]
balivernes il a connu quelques échecs
c'est vrai tu n'en as pas connu vous
avez un nouveau livre en terre bien sûr
qu'il aura mal homme s'était éteinte je
n'ai plus d'imagination allons-nous
avoir des ennuis lors bien sûr que non
je vous ai demandé de ne pas me déranger
quand je travaille la veille de noël les
esprits envahissent la nuit
écoutez monsieur dickens des voleurs des
prostituées c'est ridicule ces gens
n'ont pas leur place dans les livres
charles est reparti à repartir c'est
l'histoire d'un navarre qui la paye de
noël rencontre d esprit d sorte de guide
surnaturel quel est le titre balivernes
où la misère du vieil ami des fantômes
de noël chansons de noël
la balade de noël peut être trouvé le
nom du personnage et il apparaîtra crash
ce qu'on gère alors c'est pas beau ça
skrela l'argent de pour pas dans les
arbres
monsieur scrooge quel plaisir de vous
rencontrer
ce plaisir n'est pas partagé vous et moi
allons faire des choses extraordinaires
ensemble vous faites vous pour les
rendre aussi vivant j'arrive presque à
voir et entendre vos personnages en
forme ces derniers déjà écrit il serait
possible de l'imprimer et de les
distribuer aussi peu d'eau je ne peux
pas de finir je n'écrirai plus jamais
les personnages ne font pas ce que je
veux c'est moi l'auteur de l'histoire
ses voltiges mr et joyeux qu'est ce que
ça signifie
en fait c'est son espoir ne rejetteront
rien ni personne tout le monde sera fier
se doit le remettre à l'imprimeur avant
9 heures vous n'avez même pas écrit la
fin
un très joyeux noël à tous et chacun
ça suffit on se remet au travail
que dieu bénisse chacun de nous